hello there i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today we are doing another
very bad unboxing because my apartment
is very small and i
don't have room to do an unboxing
properly before we go any further i do
have to let you all know that
squarespace is sponsoring today's video
so i collect a lot of very weird batman
stuff
i have prime one statues i have a
vampire statue
two actually i have one that's made of
pewter ultimately i collect stuff that's
batman but like batman
looking really weird and one thing that
i have a huge preference for is
uh things that are reflective of a
specific artist which is a lot of what
the black and white line is am i getting
too specific from the jump
maybe i don't need this much detail
ultimately
this box is from jack of the dust which
is a
artist that i found on instagram just
like through my explore page
who came out with this batman skull that
i
as soon as i even saw it was like i'm a
need one of them
this is perfect for my collection and i
really love sort of trying to be more
specific
about finding specific artists who have
made
specific batman stuff specific
so uh yeah i've not opened it yet i
don't know exactly what this thing is
going to look like um
i've also kind of forgotten it's been a
while since i ordered it
so because it's not something that
you know there's just images of
everywhere it's not something that
exists in a comic necessarily um it's
very unique
i kind of don't remember what it looks
like
and i feel like that makes this one even
more exciting so yeah i found it
um as i have with another like very
unique piece of art that i ordered last
year from daniel arsham
because the artist basically uh posted
and said on their website you know you
can get this for this amount of time
pre-orders are up
um they are very limited setup is not
good it's not good
we have a box inside a box let's do it
all right slightly smaller box is upon
us
jack of the dust it's very specific
about opening it from
this side only and please wear enclosed
art handling gloves before handling this
artwork
i only have one other piece that's ever
requested that of me i think it's
very exciting we have to wear gloves to
unbox this
hmm
oh what what
so to be clear just in case anyone is
not fully aware
i did buy this from this artist this is
not sent
to me like for free i had no
communication with this person
i don't imagine they know who i am so
having this handwritten
you don't get that with your more
mainstream collectibles this rules what
the hell
it says hey alana congratulations on
securing your batman's skull
thank you for supporting jack of the
dust also
hand written very nice we have a death
certificate
that's so cool state of queensland
country of australia
wait wait wait wait wait this dude's
from queensland
that's where i'm from that's where i was
born jack of the dust i didn't know that
the skull known as jack last name not
given origin the dust was created by
andrew firth
the skull lord at jack of the dust
studios queensland australia
it has the australian coat of arms on it
you see the the top there
it's a kangaroo and an emu um
what i have not been home in too long
but this
means a ton to me i don't i don't know
why is the thing
just like it coming from australia i
haven't seen the aussie coat of arms in
way too long
uh okay also in my little sealed alana
envelope
that i'm going to keep we have the art
handling gloves
but of course nope
oh yeah that's better good stuff all
right i will say another very cool touch
here
is that the um tape also all says jack
of the dust on it
it's happening and i'm a little bit
scared
i don't know like how breakable this
thing is you know this is not
a material that i have a lot of i don't
think
it's really light though so far i still
can't make out anything really
we have a black blob but that's about it
oh wow that's a really strong smell
i don't know what that is very strong
smell this smell is probably paint
this thing
oh my god yes
it's so cool holy [ __ ] okay whoa there's
like a spring in his jaw
oh and a little wax seal damn it this is
cool
okay come on buddy get you out of here
oh my god
here we have the australian
jack of the dust batman skull
with a spring inside its mouth back here
it just says jack of the dust authentic
artwork on it oh my god
thought i'd come a little bit closer you
can see the size of this thing
do i have a big head i would have a
pretty average sized head
i would say the ears are so big
which i love i've always loved it when
they exaggerate
those fat ears
the eyes are just i think it's just
painted white but there's still some
blue shading going on in there obviously
otherwise
he's just very dark very very
black there's all these like
fracture lines across all of it
see across the top
wow oh my god
let me open the mouth for you see
unnecessary but cool
damn this is entirely my [ __ ]
so here are the proper details for you
guys
of exactly what i bought here um
obviously it is completely sold out you
were no longer able to get it
350 sf grade liquid urethane casting
resin
uh the way i create my artwork is the
same way that movie props are made first
the sculpture is hand sculpted and
molded the old school way
and from that we create a durable cast
sculpted by hand
handmade so they vary from piece to
piece which i also love it says no two
skulls will ever be the same
average weight just about two pounds and
there's your measurements that
9.8 inches wide 7.9 inches high and 8.7
inches deep my gosh
so i guess that's how it's gonna look
when i have it sitting it's either like
that one or like that one
damn but also while we're here this is
some of the other stuff you can get this
this it's all just so cool
look at that groot that's so cool i love
that the stormtrooper is amazing
um yeah i'm sure a lot of this stuff
does sell out
impossibly quickly frank skull damn
it is all incredibly cool and i guess if
this is all of it especially i'm just
like very very glad to
to own a piece of it so that is
essentially it we have unboxed
the batman skull
i love him
yep a huge fan oh my gosh
it's so cool i might just go stare at
him some more you know
i feel like that would be pretty cool so
maybe i'll go do that
who knows i'm alana i will see you guys
next time bye
i look like a mickey mouse it's time to
talk about squarespace
ladies and gentlemen squarespace gives
people a powerful and beautiful online
platform from which to create
a website you can connect with your
audience and generate revenue through
gated members only content
manage your members send email
communications and leverage audience
insights
all on one easy to use platform this is
actually something that i
highly recommend and have recommended on
my channel before for people who are
trying to get into games media if you
make a portfolio on a website that you
could make through squarespace for any
writing that you do have and then you
automatically push those samples out to
your social channels that is a great way
to get started go to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com
alana pierce to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain